bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france c'est un conflit ethnique qui se
joue entre tribus nomades arabes des
agriculteurs non arabes au sujet bien
que c'est d'abord un conflit en autour
de la terre autour des récoltes à venir
autour des villages des habitations
c'est un conflit de légitimité entre des
gens qui ont été chassés qui sont
revenus et maintenant d'autres qui
devraient de nouveau s'approprier leurs
terres je crois pas qu'on puisse
qualifier ça de conflits ethniques au
sens propre c'est simplement un conflit
peut-être qu'on peut dire entre dix
agriculteurs et des éleveurs pasteurs
nomades
donc il ya des animaux qui ont besoin de
pâturage qui ont besoin d'eau et qui
traverse cette région à la saison des
pluies pour aller chercher des pâturages
plus au nord mais sur le seul mois ils
peuvent gêner la les travaux des champs
des paysans 1,7 essentiellement ça un
autre aspect qui explique cette violence
déchaînée
c'est le fait que la région est
maintenant submergé par les armes à feu
à cause des conflits qu'il ya autour un
à la fois en libye et puis dans
tellement au tchad le fait que les
jeunes de la région sont embauchés pour
faire la guerre au yémen tout ça apporte
beaucoup d'argent sur cette région et
beaucoup de violence
alors le premier ministre soudanais a
promis dans un communiqué qu'une à force
conjointe de ces bio et dès qu'ils
mèneraient police et armée sera déployé
dans les cinq états du darfour pour
assurer la sécurité des citoyens et
protéger la saison agricole est ce que
le sous dos on a vraiment les moyens
alors le soudan on aurait les moyens
mais je crois que c'est une question de
priorité et le gouvernement de
transition démocratique à khartoum n'a
pas pris la mesure de l'urgence de
régler ce problème du darfour qui est un
peu je dirais le sel de symboles des
problèmes fondamentaux du soudan c'est à
dire entre le centre la capitale et les
périphéries la révolution elle est née
elle s'est développée déroulé
à khartoum avec des gens qui sont des
gens de la ville des citadins qui ne
comprennent pas ces régions éloignées
ces régions où les gens ne sont pas des
arabes sont musulmans au darfour
mais à partir des peuples différents
avec des langues différentes
avec une histoire différente et il ya
toujours une sorte d'apartheid le mot
est peut-être un peu fort au soudan
entre les gens du centre de la vallée du
nil qui sont de culture arabo musulmane
qui sont tournés vers le monde arabe
vers l'occident
et puis les gens les plus africain on va
dire de ces peuples des infos et
d'autres régions qui essayent de
survivre et qui ont été victimes à vous
l'avez dit depuis le 20 ans de guerre
atroce et aujourd'hui c'est la priorité
me semble-t-il pour le gouvernement
soudanais s'il veut subsister c'est de
régler ses problèmes frontaliers
ces problèmes gérait de région marginal
marginalisés et périphériques la guerre
civile au darfour a fait plusieurs
centaines de milliers de morts 2,5
millions de déplacés selon l'onu
est ce qu'on peut dire que les violences
font ont baissé en intensité depuis la
chute du président omar el-béchir en
avril 2019 avait dans un premier temps
oui hein mais je crois qu'il y avait une
bonne volonté de la part des
manifestants qui ont fait tomber
omar al béchir qui ne connaissent pas le
darfour c'est assez frappant et je les
ai vécus wamen voir en rentrant du
darfour que les gens de khartoum ne
pouvait pas imaginer ne pouvais pas
croire les atrocités qui se déroulait
sur place alors aujourd'hui il ya une
volonté de compréhension mais en même
temps il ya tant de problèmes au soudan
aujourd'hui de problèmes à la fois
financier et économique mais aussi de re
fondation du pays que le le gouvernement
me semble-t-il a été un petit peu léger
il a laissé venir la saison des pluies
où se déroulent les travaux agricoles
mais où les tensions renesse aussi
simplement
depuis la fin de la grande guerre d
argent de la contre-insurrection
criminelle qui a été menée de 2003 à
2005 on va dire ou 2006 au darfour la
situation s'était plus ou moins apaisé
il ya des groupes rebelles qui
continuent à garder les armes et à se
battre dans les montagnes mais
finalement la paix civile si on peut
dire était revenu même si les deux
millions et demi de déplacés dont vous
parlez ne sont toujours pas rentrés chez
eux un toutou deux derniers mois et ce
qu'est ce qu'il faut craindre
aujourd'hui une résurgence de la guerre
civile en janvier dernier on le rappelle
était signé un accord entre le
gouvernement une coalition de neuf
groupes rebelles est ce qu elle tient
toujours cet accord enquête cet accord
est transitoire cd ça n'est qu'à cessez
le feu ce n'est pas un accord de paix ça
n'est pas un accord sur la refondation
du soudan sur le partage des places aux
6,1 et du budget national de le diable
est dans les détails si vous voulez
aujourd'hui les négociations continuent
à djouba au sud soudan entre ces
mouvements qui sont eux mêmes divisés et
qui ont des options différents
politiquement religieusement et le
gouvernement central
et puis il faut bien dire aussi que le
vrai patron du soudan aujourd'hui est
originaire du darfour mais c'est un
criminel en chef si vous voulez c'est
lui qui dirigeait les opérations contre
les victimes d'aujourd'hui et maintenant
il est si vous voulez enrichi par les
mines d'or par les trafics avec l'arabie
saoudite et les d'envoi de mercenaires
sur place il a une armée de mercenaires
est plus importante que l'armée
nationale et c'est lui qui mène le bal
en sous main donc il ya beaucoup de
choses encore qui n'apparaissent pas
clairement dans cette éruption de
violence à laquelle on assiste
merci beaucoup pour votre regard marc
lavergne directeur de recherche au cnrs
spécialiste de la corne de l'afrique